haremos la siguiente suma tenemos 7
puntos 0 56 más 600 5.7 + 5.67 tenemos
diferentes unidades con decimales
haremos lo que hemos hecho anteriormente
y es acomodar nuestros números donde el
punto se alinea y entonces podamos
distinguir las unidades de los decimales
así es que tendremos 7
no hay no pinta
7 el punto me gusta ponerlo en blanco
0 56 más
605 volveré a poner el punto
y el 605 es unidad por lo tanto irá
hacia la izquierda
600 5.7
más
5.67 el 5 es unidad por lo tanto lo
pondré a la izquierda correcto y el 67 a
la derecha
todo esto lo sumaremos como les
comentaba en vídeos anteriores
estos números podemos rellenarlos ya que
están vacíos para que se vea un solo
bloque aquí tendremos un cero aquí
tendremos otro cero y aquí un cero si
eliminó la caja nos quedará de la
siguiente manera 0 0 y un solo 0 así
tenemos tres columnas completas hacia la
derecha vamos a hacer nuestra suma y
recuerden lo haremos de derecha a
izquierda para poder ir llevando o
arrastrando números en caso de que nos
quede mayor que
la columna que estamos utilizando y sea
necesario llevarlo o cargarlo hacia la
siguiente columna así es que empecemos
cuánto es 600 es igual a 6
57 es igual a 12 aquí tenemos ese caso
por lo que el 12 lo pondremos como un
dos extremos llevándonos o arrastrando
este uno hacia la izquierda y estamos
llevando 1 101 más 7 886 es igual a 14
ponemos el 4 y nos llevaremos el 1 hacia
la columna de las unidades así es que
ahora tenemos uno más 7 885 13 13 5 18 y
nos llevaremos uno hacia la siguiente
columna que es la de las decenas 1 + 0
es igual a 1 y entonces este 6 bajará
directamente porque ya no tenemos nada
más que llevar y tenemos que no
olvidemos por favor el punto una vez más
tenemos alineados nuestros puntos y por
lo tanto tenemos la separación entre
unidades y decimales
así es que 7.156 605 puntos 7 más 5
puntos 67 es igual a 600 18.426 o lo que
es lo mismo
618 unidades más 426 milésimas
vamos claros seguiremos practicando nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo